even though the calendar says june 24th
there's still a lot happening in the nfl
no slow time this year
trying to figure out what training camp
is going to be trying to figure out how
they're going to handle the coronavirus
protocols and that leads into
what i think is the top story right now
when you have the nfl players
association telling its constituents
in no uncertain terms
do not
engage in private workouts until
training camp do not put yourself in a
position where you may subject yourself
or your family members
to the coronavirus and the illness covet
19 that comes from it don't do it don't
do it now it's not like they can
they can
order them not to do it but when your
union that has one primary purpose which
is to protect you
and advance your interest says don't do
it probably makes sense to not do it and
here's what makes even more sense chris
if you're going to break that
recommendation i don't want to say rule
it's not a rule but if you're not going
to adhere to the recommendation don't
flaunt it like tom brady did this is on
social media yesterday
him standing
fewer than six feet away from rob
gronkowski with the caption no excuses
so the message from the nfl pa no
workouts the message from tom brady no
excuses and and what does that do it
sends a message to every other team out
there hey
we're doing it suckers and if you're
paying attention to the nfl pa and and
they're they're they're afraid they're
hiding under the bed they want you to
they want you to stay at home they want
you to be live in fear we're out here
doing what we need to do we'll see you
in september what do you think it's
going to cause of the teams to do chris
it's not going to call the other teams
to stay home they're going to go out and
do it too
no i i know that uh you know this is a
this is a tough one for in a lot of
different ways i mean yes we know like
the coronavirus is still very relevant
in our country it's spreading in a lot
of our country and states it's we're
we're seeing that it's there's new hot
spots coming up everywhere i get it you
know and hey listen i want to be the
first to tell you we kind of bagged on
dak prescott when he did it early on you
know when the pandemic started and
everything
but times have kind of changed over the
last few months and as much as like i
respect the nfl pa and i understand what
they're saying mike i mean this is a
conversation we had as a player i mean
okay you can't play quarterback unless
you get to some teammates and start
throwing some footballs around and doing
stuff like that and again it goes into
the the psychosis of i don't think a lot
of nfl players are in fear of this i
understand your point too about sharing
it on social media i wish tom brady
didn't do that but i can't sit here and
honestly say that if i was a quarterback
of a national football league team right
now and it was the end of june yeah i
don't care nfl pa i know i like you and
respect you but i got a job to do and
i'm not worried about getting around my
teammates and you telling me not to do
it when we're all gonna be around each
other like three or four weeks from now
anyways and be hitting each other
sweating on each other bleeding on each
other and all those things too so i
think the psychosis of a tom brady is
okay let's go to work i'm gonna be in
this situation three or four weeks from
now anyways
i i don't disagree with much of what you
said but i want to be clear on one thing
when we criticize dak prescott that was
at a time when the country was on
lockdown and there were violations of
stay-at-home orders that were implicated
here the tuatanga vailoa workout that
was done before the draft that was in
violation of the nashville stay-at-home
order that was in place at the time the
facility shouldn't have let him and his
entourage in there they shouldn't have
been in there that's what was going on
in the world at the time now you're
right everything's opening up and oh by
the way the pandemic is racing through
the population in certain states no one
seems to care about that it's it's i
mean it really is this has been this
this whole year has been the twilight
zone and it never ends and there's
always some new twist to the twilight
zone where you feel like you're thrown
into some warped twisted upside down
reality but where we are now is this
on sunday
the nfl players association made it
clear
and i know they have no authority to
punish discipline enforce the the the
rule of the recommendation where we want
to call it but they made it clear and
and if you're not going to follow it i
think that you are basically giving your
union the middle finger you are
undermining your union you are working
against the group that is in place to
advance your interests
you are hurting their credibility by
flaunting it that's what bothers me the
most about it if the union hadn't said
anything that we could say well you know
tom brady he's doing tom brady things
and he's working hard he's getting his
guys ready he's not violating any
ordinances in florida right now yeah you
know you may want to be careful the
virus is tearing through florida right
now but they're young and they're fine
and you know you can say all that stuff
but once the union says don't do it and
once brady decides to turn it into a
social media catalog of photos it's just
one middle finger after another
at the nfl players association let me
give you a contrast here we reported
last week that kyla murray was bringing
20 members of the cardinals to dallas
for workouts from sunday through today
and
on it was saturday not sunday when the
nflpa said what it said
and i tried to find out is this still
happening crickets nothing radio silence
which tells me they're still doing it
but they're not making a big deal about
it they're not putting stuff on social
media saying hey look at us now they may
now now that brady has but there's a
discretion that i think is critical here
because you are undermining your union
undermining it
and and that's what that's the separate
thing that that i think is so
problematic about what tom brady's doing
i mean the guy he's 42 years old he's
been around the nfl for 20 years you'd
think he would understand you'd think
that the ego and the vanity that prompts
you to post this stuff on social media
would take a back seat to recognizing
i'm really not helping my union here by
doing this stuff
well i i don't think any of that takes a
back seat for tom brady right now in his
world you know it's like the old jay-z
saying like i'm not a businessman i'm a
businessman and like brady's business
and his his entity is himself and this
and i think that's how he looks at it
now like mike i'm with you i totally
agree like it is a middle finger to the
nfl pa i don't understand sharing it on
social media when we know the pandemic
is far serious than our president and
some other people want to make it out to
be right now and i think that could be
part of the problem too okay i mean you
know you look at examples that are out
there and we have some leadership that
doesn't seem to care as much as others
but either way you know i just think
with the carelessness of yes releasing
it on social media and doing those
things i don't like that
uh and agree with you you could do these
things in private but i just don't think
you could tell again our old saying here
like a 42 or a 43 year old man hey you
know this might be one of your last
years of your career don't prepare that
hard for it wait till we get to training
camp i mean you're just not going to
tell alpha male you know psycho too much
testosterone type people this type of
stuff at this point of the year when
they know their lives
their lives and their livelihoods depend
on how they perform here in a few months
in football and training camp and things
like that so uh i don't think you're
gonna stop the workouts despite the
greatest recommendations for the nflpa
or any of that it's going to continue to
go on and you know i don't mean to say
this disrespectfully but if i was
playing quarterback like i said earlier
i'd be doing it too i don't think i'd be
throwing it on social media but i
certainly would have receivers together
and be trying to improve my craft and
get myself in shape for football
here's something else to keep in mind
that addresses a point you made earlier
you said they're going to be together in
a few weeks anyway
doing the things they're doing now so
what's the difference here's the
difference when they get together for
training camp there will be protocols
that apply there will be screening that
is done there will be testing that is
done
i don't think tom brady is swabbing
noses or mouths before he lets these
guys out onto the practice field and
when you're on the practice field i
think there will be efforts to keep guys
apart as best they can there will be
moments where it's unavoidable
but there will be moments where
it is avoidable and you don't have to
have guys on top of each other shereen
williams had a great idea yesterday that
that uh
maybe they'll put speakers in everyone's
helmet so you don't have to huddle
during games this year anything you can
do to avoid situations where guys
cluster together maybe you find a way to
do it and i think there will be
procedures during training camp
to to ensure
the ultimate degree of safety under the
circumstances there's a certain amount
of it that's going to go out the window
when it's time to actually say hike or
hut or yeah or go or whatever the magic
words depending upon what your offense
is omaha right but before that there are
things that can be done to minimize the
risk and my guess is when guys are
getting together at the local high
school field they're not thinking about
that so that's a reason to maybe wait
because i think there will be
best practices and procedures and
concepts that apply when it's time to go
to training camp that these guys just
aren't thinking about
no i think you're right about that and
i'm glad you cleared that up because
you're right when you do get the
training camp it's going to be much
stricter protocol and things like that
it's still going to be 100 fail-safe and
you know hey i know we we talk about
like it is a great idea for shireen that
might be something like but sharing is
talking about that might be something
regardless forget the pandemic or
anything we might we maybe we should put
speakers in every player's ear so they
can just
know the play straight from the sideline
and speed up the pace of the game or
whatever it may be but you know still
the social distancing during practice
and oh we're going to find ways like
who cares what does it matter if we were
just in a scrum 20 minutes ago and now
we're separate are we thinking that's
like whoa we're staying away from the
virus those 20 minutes together in like
our goal line stand period uh that was
okay but now we're separate and we're
doing drills on you know separate fields
and we're not covering people i don't
even understand that that's where i
think you're hearing like john
harbaugh's of the world and things like
that when they're talking about practice
they're just like how the hell does this
happen what are we gonna do i don't get
it and uh
you know it goes back to my my old adage
mike where i just i i wish we'd get a
little farther down the law of the road
here of the comfort where players might
be with this discussion can we get them
in lockdown for a full month and just go
through this and see what happens and uh
and are players comfortable with getting
covered 19 but i just don't know where
this goes right now as we go on i'm
getting less and less optimistic that
we're gonna have football this year i'm
sorry to be pessimistic because that's
where i feel right now
well and and
we had that vibe last week and i
contacted
some somebody who knows
what's going on behind the curtain and i
was led to believe there is still a very
high degree of optimism that there will
be football this year now i i think that
it would be prudent at some point for
the nfl to disseminate information that
would allow the rest of us to reach that
same conclusion but as we mentioned the
other day the idea that they believe
based upon studying the way this virus
works
outdoors in a an open environment even
if you're in a dome even though you're
not outdoors in an open environment the
virus doesn't linger in the air long
enough
to invade the eyes and the noses of
other people it's in those contained
settings in a weight room and the
speculation has been that the outbreaks
we're seeing at the college level if
they're happening on the clock of the
football program they're happening in
the weight room where the air is heavy
and guys are exhaling and other guys are
in there and those those droplets are
just there they they just hang around
for someone to walk through them they
think that that's not going to be the
case when it comes time to to get onto a
practice field or get onto a game field
and the idea is do everything you can to
make sure nobody gets on a field who may
be positive so they still are optimistic
so i look and and and i have tried to be
realistic about yeah the virus not
pessimistic or optimistic just realistic
because the virus sets the agenda here
with all that said
i i i think that
the the
the optimism
hasn't been shared the way that it could
be or should be and at some point over
the next few weeks they need to do a
good job of letting us all know why
they're optimistic chris yeah that's
right why why are they optimistic you
know that's what i need to start knowing
you know start start getting it out
there what is it that you know or that
you're gonna do that's going to
make this work but right now you know
for lack of a better way to say it it
seems a little flimsy i mean it does it
just oh okay yeah
we're not going to work out in the gym
together and those droplets won't matter
you know i just i don't know and again i
know there's a lot of unknowns about the
pandemic and covet 19 still that we
don't know about that virus either we're
still learning more and more about it i
know we have more knowledge now than we
did you know a few months ago but uh i
just still think there is between the
virus the unknown's there and then yes
the unknowns of how the nfl is going to
approach this and what are they going to
do
if one guy gets it or two guys get it or
a whole group of guys get it on a few
teams during the middle of a training
camp how is that going to work it's just
so many questions you're right and i
wish the nfl would you know ease our
minds a little bit to
you know show us
the pathway here as far as how this will
be successful and work
and i think one thing is clear if
somebody's positive they're getting shut
down for the required period of time
until they're no longer positive they're
not going to say well go ahead and you
know everybody else will just assume the
risk and stay away from the guy that's
positive you're getting shut down the
question is how do you backfill the spot
on the roster and that's yeah what if
it's 20 guys that's right
what yeah that's where it gets real
dicey to me
and and apparently baseball is thinking
about doing something like this and i've
mentioned this i don't know if we've
talked about it on the show i've done
some radio spots i think the pftpm
podcast has come up but the xfl had a
ninth team during its five or six weeks
of operation where there was a separate
team
of players who went through the regular
practices and they were ready to go and
if one of the other teams needed a guy
we got a guy who's game ready it's not
some guy that we're we're we're calling
away from some other job that doesn't
entail him staying in the best possible
shape so i think the nfl needs to have
four rosters like that get hugh jackson
to coach one jeff fisher to coach
another a couple of other guys that are
out there that may be inclined to get
back in a locker room and keep guys
ready so so if there is an outbreak on a
team they've got a bunch of guys who are
ready to go you're not calling guys off
the couch chris i think that is
something they need to be doing they
need to be thinking about and that will
allow them to be prepared
in the event there is the kind of
outbreak that would otherwise shut a
team down yeah right i mean it gives you
wiggle room that's for sure i mean i i
might i mean i know you've been saying
this from the get-go and i agree with
you you know you're right and it needs
to be more than one team
of guys because you know for the reasons
we were just talking about you know if
if let's just say the nfc east somehow
you know those teams played each other
on a sunday and now it's like whoa we
got like 15 guys
on each team that got covered 19 we
don't know how it happened whatever blah
blah blah you know one team is not going
to be able to fix or fill all these
holes so we better have more guys behind
the scenes here and you're right there
maybe that's the right approach um but
again these are just yeah these are
things that
uh i i don't know and you know mike what
i want to ask you and i meant to look
this up you know before we started the
show what what is the premier league
doing right now to make this work do you
do we know anything about their testing
procedures and how they're going about
practice because i i do find it
interesting that they're kind of moving
forward and going in the right direction
and we don't hear many hiccups there
i haven't looked carefully at what the
premier league is doing with any degree
of specificity but it's working so far
yeah they're playing the games i know at
tottenham which is the combination nfl
stadium and premier league stadium and
it's not like this is going to be
available at every venue they actually
move the teams into the nfl locker room
because it's so much bigger
than the
the soccer locker room so they were able
to spread out more in the nfl locker
rooms at that stadium but but yeah look
they're making it work and
that doesn't mean all of a sudden it's
going to not work and it's also a
different country that's taking a
different approach to this and they have
laid the foundation for this to happen
so i look the bottom line is
anything that goes on with other sports
the nfl is going to be studying it it's
part of the benefit that the nfl has
just locked into by
the way the calendar is structured this
thing hit at a time when the nfl was
just starting its off season and it's
got the benefit of seeing what is going
on with the premier league what will
happen with the nba
next month in orlando baseball back in a
month
unless something happens there nhl
planning to come back so the nfl can can
watch all of that and study all that and
look i got to mention one other thing
about the videos of tom brady and
company working out he's not the only
one russell wilson
working out too and the video surfacing
as well
and
and and look now now
that that looks a lot different
from
what we saw in tampa that they're about
60 feet apart not six feet apart
but still
the union has said don't do it
and i would i'm surprised that that
russell wilson
who is very very concerned about
perception and image and has always been
that way it's not a knock
it's fine to be that way either be that
way or not that way he is that way i'm
surprised that he would post something
like that
just days after the nflpa says guys
don't do this not a good idea to do it
maybe his thought is well people are
going to see these and they're going to
realize that this this isn't
maybe maybe in a roundabout way this is
his way of showing the other guys if
you're going to do it this is how you
have to do it you can't have 10 guys out
there you can play pitch and catch with
a guy who stays away from you but you
can't be on top of each other like we
saw from the videos from the the brady
workouts with his buccaneers teammates
well yeah i mean you know it certainly
seems safer what russell wilson's doing
and yeah you know you're right he is
very perception you know conscious right
about what he looks like but i think
he's looking at also going man you know
screw my perception i want to be you
know perceived as the best quarterback
in football in 2020 so he's worried
about that you know first off and and
foremost and you know i think he'd
rather have a perception of a guy that's
a great worker and obsessed with being a
quarterback and all those things too but
i i just
again i don't think there's any safe way
one guy five guys whatever it is i mean
there's going to be sweat on that
football from dk metcalf that goes onto
the football and then russell wilson's
going to have it and then you know
somebody's going to rub their eye or
lick their hand to grab the football
better and you're swapping germs right
away and now you're doing it so you know
i don't think there's going to be any
perfect method here but i can't again i
just got i can't stress enough you know
these are grown men this is their
profession this is what they do
and they're obsessive compulsive about
it especially quarterbacks and
especially quarterbacks like brady and
russell wilson and you know they'll
stress out and go crazy if i know these
people the right way and know what their
makeup is of i mean i i haven't thrown i
haven't done anything i'm not ready for
training cam what what is this it's just
not realistic to ask grown men who love
their job and their profession to not do
anything with other players and
teammates to get better going into the
nfl season it's not realistic we're
seeing all sports do it baseball
basketball they're all practicing
together a little bit
one last point very quickly and i'm no
epidemiologist i'm just sharing the
things oh you're not lean from studying
it right but but i do know that the
green isn't grass here i do know that i
don't exactly be a botanist but but uh
but but i'll say this look and and the
the things you're talking about touching
your eyes touching your head you're
touching the ball i i think that one of
the things they've learned over the past
few months the biggest risk for
transmission is the airborne droplets
under those circumstances where it's a
confined space and someone
breathes loudly talks loudly sends that
virus out into the air and it has the
opportunity to hang there and somebody
else has
in that proximity the opportunity to
have it absorbed into their eyes and
their nose that's the concern i'm not
saying that the rest of the ways of
getting it aren't but the big concern is
the droplet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports